une série hier s'est passé quelque chose
de grave
gravissime gravissime aux grammy simus
faux latin
[Musique]
la règle était clair aucun portable
ne devaient être ramenés sur le plateau
une personne
à ramener son cellulaire la star comment
je le sais grâce aux instincts story ah
bah oui oui bah qui est assez bête pour
hanouna oui né de la dernière pluie non
excellent manager de leur moi c'est bien
sûr et bien sûr qu est ce que vous avez
fait c'est quoi les cas attention quelle
excuse j'ai mis des instincts story pour
bien pousser les missions couchant moi
je met une instance tories pour vous
poussez pas vraiment la nuit je vous le
dis je ne veux plus de portable sur le
plateau